[Music]
hey what's up welcome to every damn day
today we debate who is the best
South Park villain of all time but first
let's preview this week's episode of
South Park
hey don't you wish you had more quality
one-on-one time with your phone
odd bifold with parents and
relationships imagine being able to shut
them out for a little while Craig so you
can focus on what matters with Buddha
box you can cut out all the unwanted
noise not have to deal with
conversations that are of no interest to
you well I have to admit sub-types would
be a tweeker together it's it's like
'hey what's my tension all the time but
I'm about to blow your minds but Cartman
Dylan let's weigh it he's cooked the kid
fed him to his friends he's also kind of
racist I mean we've heard I talked to
token I gotta always bring up token
because he's the only black guy on the
show and I'm only black on this show I
understand token but is he the most evil
of all time I don't know just to make
sure we we have a unbiased debate today
we're gonna have two guests on the show
and they're gonna plead the case for who
they think is the most evil person or a
South Park of all time is and I'm gonna
let them introduce themselves you know
what it is I'm here I'm new school Chris
you know I'm saying doing what I do you
know I'm saying cuz he trying to tell me
with young kids like I'm trying to tell
him he over flat out he old my name is
old school Chris and I'll be speaking on
behalf of old South Park you remember
the good old days back when it was
cardboard cutouts and chef was just
giving cookies to the kids I want to
shout out you know I mean any other
seasons over season 17 that's when the
magic really came together all the rest
of that was practice I mean before
beauty dawg do you this wasted on the
young
now my villainous is old as time itself
saying he's the best all-time with him
because he's old as time itself take a
look
if I go spend the night with Saddam that
it's over between me and Chris Chris has
been so nice to me and I know Saddam
will just hurt me again maybe I'll just
go talk to Saddam I need closure yeah
that's it I need closure what am i doing
Saddam I'm just here to talk
Saddam I only came here because I need
closure no Saddam listen to me Jack
again maybe just a little one I have to
go back soon I need you to understand
that we can't be together anymore I need
you to not come by the condo and not try
to see me Chris thinks we can all be
friends but I don't and I have to focus
on Chris now what is this Saddam will
you listen to me Chris is a great person
he's the one I want to be with now drink
too much Chris
oh no Satan on South Park was the most
evil because he had a heart of gold and
I don't know if you noticed I threw in
Saddam Hussein for free the thing about
saying it makes him so great is he can
create even from scratch he will beat up
Jesus sometimes you can't no man should
be laying hands on Jesus and plus he
cheated on his boyfriend and another
thing is anybody everybody knows if you
got Lawrence and you're ready even
that's just the way I was raised
let you spin around be given the town
just like you huh let me show you who
the most evil things ever are don't add
up
[Music]
yeah that's even the member bags are
evil cuz they play mind games there's
nothing more evil than your own sauce
that's what they do they get you in the
place where you can't have the escape
and blueberries blueberries themselves
are very popular fruit they're very cute
and adorable
then how to get you with the real evil
because they choking hazard that's why
they kill you from the inside out you
know something you know I'm in the band
made me remember that I hate old
but you're both wrong the most evil
villain of all time it's mr. garrison
check this out mr. president
congratulations mr. president
looks like many more years of the same
are to come oh I don't think so
I think the next three years are gonna
be even better that's evil this dude is
on the same evil scale as the Joker
he killed off mr. hat he also has the
worst cartoon spray-on tan I've ever
seen and he also made cartoon paul ryan
cry hands down as mr. garrison I hear
old Chris he talking about
just sayin new Chris talking about his
member berries hey i it look delicious
to me and I mean it's something I was
amazing you had a good point with
Cartman let me know in the comments talk
to me I want to hear what you got to say
I might be smiling some of y'all I know
you need to like comment and subscribe
what - this here
[Music]